hey friends welcome back to the deep
dive snippet this is a clip from my
conversation with patricia bright and
we're talking about how to truly find
work you love and in this clip we're
talking about the somewhat
counterintuitive advice that following
your passion is like generally a dead
end when it comes to actually finding
work that you love with a few caveats so
i hope you enjoyed this clip you know a
lot of
the internet would say hey fine find
your passion and follow that passion i
don't believe in that oh you don't
believe in that don't believe in
passions i absolutely think that's so
dead
sorry i just interrupted you but
i don't believe in like
the idea of following a passion
especially if you're broke or you're
hungry because passion may not put food
on the table and passion isn't gonna pay
the rent right so once you've been able
to kind of
deal with those bases those basics there
like get those covered and then i think
it's about you defining like
what is something you have skills in
doing now
and um
you again are interested in you can
execute in that kind of those key areas
and
i wouldn't call that passion i'll just
call it what i call it like working on
your strengths or
or like playing to your strengths that
kind of thing yeah playing to your
strengths but just doing something so
like sometimes that that you you're
waiting for passion to come or like a a
wind of inspiration to come and it's not
going to come you're going to wait
forever so it's better to just do
something anything it doesn't even have
to be the thing that you're passionate
about or you like maybe it's a thing you
can do right there and then it might be
like
oh i'm not passionate okay let me just
you know read the book or clean my room
or make a meal or
go on a walk doing something versus
doing nothing is a good idea um yeah
it's kind of like what cal newport talks
about in so good they can't ignore you
uh he talks about this idea of
kind of follow follow your passion is
really terrible advice because as you
said you know you're pr i'm passionate
about playing the guitar the chances of
me making a career out of playing the
guitar are minuscule
and uh instead if you aim to become
really good at something then a passion
often develops for the thing that you
are then really good at i love that and
then you can
as you become good at the thing it then
gives you
career capital and often the thing that
makes people passionate about their job
is a sense of autonomy a sense of
freedom a sense that they can do what
they want with their time and if you're
really good at something you can then
negotiate autonomy even if you even if
you're not an entrepreneur or a creator
even as an employee you can
find that passion but you have to become
good at something first rather than
thinking oh i'm passionate about guitar
i'm passionate about football i'm
obviously going to make a career out of
that which is just kind of generally
unrealistic for most people exactly i
even say this i'm actually passionate
about eating sweets and chocolate and
watching netflix but that is not going
to be helpful for me in the long run if
i just focus on binging on shows and
eating
high calorie snacks that aren't good for
me
hey friends thank you so much for
watching if you enjoyed this clip then
click here for the full unedited episode
and if you like that then do please
consider subscribing to the channel it
means a lot thank you so much and have a
great day